the wilderness is an unforgiving place
there are so many different ways to die
out there we've covered a lot of
striving tactics and situations like a
lot a lot but unless you know you're
gonna be attacked by a bear you might
have missed that one video about what to
do when you're attacked by a bear that's
why this video may save your life okay
you're stranded in the wilderness
congratulations what do you do first
whether in the woods in the mountains
were on a deserted island here are a few
essential steps survivalists say to
follow first signal for rescue
the sooner you return to civilization
the better your best chance of escape is
to be rescued so use your resources to
signal any ships or planes that might
pass by but if rescue doesn't come the
next step is to avoid injury your feet
are some of your most important and
vulnerable tools for survival boots will
protect you from cutting your feet as
you explore the area for the next step
to survival find fresh water while a
human can survive for 40 days without
food
we can't live more than eight to ten
days without water if you have to choose
between dehydration and unfiltered water
take your chances with the water but if
you can fresh water is gonna be your
best bet sources of fresh water include
caves rain and making your own from salt
water if you're by the ocean you can
convert salt water to fresh fill a can
with salt water and then put a second
container over the can this will collect
the fresh water that evaporates out of
the can you need at least one liter of
water per day to survive look for signs
of life if you can't find a water source
vegetation birds and insects can all
mean nearby water sources roots
vegetables and cacti can all contain
water and mashing them with a rock will
release some liquid water flows downhill
so be sure to check low terrain canyons
and mountain bases that could be home to
a water source morning dew can be
collected with a cloth and then wrung
out into your mouth but just make sure
you collect it before sunrise
or it could evaporate before you get to
it if you're lucky enough to catch a
rainfall use cups or any possible
containers to catch it if possible build
a water catching tart this will allow
even more water to be collected
so hopefully this never happens to you
but let's say you found yourself in an
extreme situation you're out of food
you're out of water and the only liquid
nearby is your own the army has a Field
Manual which has a do not drink list for
just such an occasion that list includes
fish juices blood alcohol sea water and
yes urine drinking urine is basically
like drinking seawater it's going to
dehydrate you which is the exact
opposite of what you want to make
matters worse if you keep drinking it
the severe dehydration can trigger
abnormally low blood pressure low blood
pressure means less blood flow to vital
organs like your heart lungs and kidney
which can be damaged or fail as a result
that is not good adding to your trouble
is urea urea is basically waste it's not
supposed to be in your body that's why
your kidneys filter it out of your blood
and into your urine which ordinarily
then just leaves your body but if you
then drink the urine your kidneys have
to work twice as hard to filter out that
extra urea and that could lead to kidney
failure it seems like drink and urine
might be your kidneys worst nightmare
just stick with fresh water if you can
get it you should also know how to build
a fire you need a dry patch of ground
about four feet wide build a ring of
rocks or dig down a few inches this will
keep the fire insulated then use paper
dry grass or pine needles as tinder pile
loosely in the center and top with
kindling if that kindlings wet you're
gonna need a lot more tinder if you're
lucky enough to have a lighter or
matches ignite the tinder and gently
blow on the fire if you don't have a
lighter or matches you need to use
friction to create an ember you can also
create sparks with a flint and steel if
you need to you could always use a lens
to harness the sun's light as the
kindling catches gradually add
more once you have a nice healthy flame
going begin to add the firewood arrange
the pieces in a teepee shape this fire
will burn hot and quickly so be sure to
keep it fed as you explore the area you
might be trying to find your way back to
civilization
you may remember hearing how Moss only
grows on the north side of trees great
right unfortunately that's a myth
moss grows wherever conditions are moist
and cool this is often the north side of
trees since they are less likely to
receive direct sunlight but in the woods
trees can be shaded from any direction
so it's not safe to go by this role
there are some unseen dangers that could
definitely slow you down you should also
know how to deal with these chances are
you won't encounter quicksand that often
but just in case you do here's how to
escape quicksand first of all don't
panic it's impossible to drowned in
quicksand because humans actually float
in it what makes it so dangerous is its
viscosity once disturbed quicksand
becomes much more viscous trapping
whatever it envelops don't ask your
friend to pull you out they'll only be
able to dislodge your top half and
that's no good here's how you get out of
it wiggle your legs to create a pocket
for water to trickle down this will
loosen the sand around your legs feel
free to lose your shoes if you have to
next lay back the more you distribute
your weight across the surface the
harder it will be to sink now work on
your backstroke use your arms to propel
yourself backwards the quicksand will
actually keep you afloat
and you'll be able to pull your legs
free once you reach solid ground roll
away from the quicksand and then you'll
be clear of that sticky situation Mother
Nature isn't the only danger out here
wildlife is also a threat if you don't
know how to react appropriately like
snakes most snakes will avoid you but if
you happen to get bitten by venomous
snakes you can always suck the venom out
right nope that is another myth a
venomous bite delivers the venom
straight to your bloodstream
in fact trying to suck it out could
transfer the venom to your mouth it
could also further infect the wound
instead hold the bitten limb below or
close to heart level this may prevent
the venom from reaching your heart if
you're in some parts of the world you
have a good chance of running across
some bears do not take out your phone
and think ooh there's a bear I'm gonna
get a photograph of it you see it there
that bear hasn't seen you the best thing
to do is slowly
backstep yourself out of the situation
if you do encounter bear and that bear
does you more times than not the bear is
actually more afraid of you than you
should be a bit and it will take off on
its own now if you are attacked do not
try to outrun a bear I know a lot of
people out there who say I could outrun
a bear you can't outrun a bear however
if it makes a threat toward you make
yourself look big scream crazy do
whatever you can in the event of an
attack by a black bear the most
important thing you can do is fight for
your life a grizzly bear however is much
larger much more powerful and way out of
our league for a hand-to-hand fight with
a grizzly bear your best chance of
survival is to curl up in a ball play
dead and cry for your mama protect your
head and your neck just hold on there
isn't all they can be very painful ride
oftentimes that bear will end up leaving
and going on give yourself a few minutes
endure through the pain and once you
know that the animal has moved off into
the underbrush that's when you quietly
get yourself up and you go seek medical
attention as quick as possible probably
the most important lesson to survive in
an unfamiliar area is to become familiar
with it study the terrain environment
and wildlife of any new area before you
enter it let people know where you will
be and how long you'll be out there and
bring the necessary gear for that trip
in every emergency situation that you
can think of using these tips hopefully
you'll never need to drink your own pee
in the first place